hundreds of people marching through
Washington to condemn racial hatred the
year after a white supremacist rally in
Charlottesville turned deadly
these counter-demonstrators far
outnumbered a white nationalist protest
which was also being held in the US
Capitol it's vital that we don't allow
white supremacists and open fascists to
take the street uncontested
I don't want Nazis and white
supremacists to speak for me I thought
it was important to come out so that
there's other voices to counteract them
this empowerment of people who think
that their comfort comfort supersedes
people's rights is way out of line and
because of a skin tone is ridiculous the
group of around 20 white nationalists
was much smaller than expected it was
escorted by hundreds of police officers
who were out enforced to ensure no
clashes erupted the organizers
downplayed their role in last year's
violence
to follow a federal court judge
allow that demonstration to take place I
mean
it is a tragedy what happens but it's
not going to happen this year in
Charlottesville where the far-right was
forbidden to rally this year largely
peaceful commemoration events were held
last year hundreds of white nationalists
descended on the city to protest the
removal of a monument and Confederate
General Robert E Lee the rally turned
violent as protesters clashed with
counter protesters culminating the death
of Heather hire who was killed when a
man drove his car into a crowd back in
Washington a downpour brought an end to
a day of remembrance and protest without
any violence